oh man we have got ourselves into some
[ __ ] okay we're back we're back for a
boat in this [ __ ]
we're boat in this shot let's do this hi
dad guys slaving
we had a system wipe but the [ __ ] Anna
beam Anna beam brass life okay start it
now
oh there are you did this right there
des I'm experienced user yeah yeah take
some auto often late J's ribs Oh ribs
are good everyone was surprised
okay and now gas lambs had yes yes yes
okay okay sorry you had to go through
that again guys
now honey had at the end I got some
email
[Music]
come on fetch and beam
okay there's some [ __ ] that shows up
here Baroness it's this [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
you are safe
as [ __ ] bad English
hey I am okay we're doing this again you
know I'm just gonna skip ahead
[ __ ] says we're [ __ ] back okay so
let's do this nothing is what it seems
okay okay we're back this [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
phone didn't reset
it's not about two minutes all this [ __ ]
Craig you're like the worst person I
think of second weird
I need some [ __ ] battery here what is
what is it porn stash
hmm that's weird okay then send all that
[ __ ] over let's get started at bench
Creek you like the worst boys that day
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah I got it
got a whole chunk of stiff that I get
all chuckles dev what yes
[Music]
what are you implying [ __ ]
[Music]
so check
[Music]
nothing much
[Music]
okay I can't you talk about that guy all
day any more pictures I could've sworn
that's more pictures in here
well I can't we got some goodies here
we're just gonna do this surfer fast
Paris and Kay an extension 0 405 your
Lander shares more stuff that way yeah
birth control stick okay it's so much
quicker just to [ __ ] click it yep
steps and to sit walk on lower clicking
babies mark clicking mark clucking eCos
more success appearing again maybe I'll
[ __ ] do this
oh look anyone inconclusive not pregnant
so someone is slogging her and I need to
know he'll study leave hey application
Boston doing office I'll explain said
him application my two-week study leave
oh yeah she's trying to [ __ ] leave
we're in for a shipment consumer society
mister structures objects its
presentation aid looks like you're
seeing for next week companies well I
don't know that gifts are meant to be
secret but not given that we go once a
preconditioned detect right there
I will tell me your size and I will pick
pick the perfect dress for you tell me
your body size be your body size and I
will pick
take the perfect dress
whoa okay MuRF
you some insults on office where mert
what a [ __ ] creeper oh traveling
who's this [ __ ] [ __ ] boring jabber
no spark someone comment it out [ __ ] I
got it here in the comments see you all
goofball fine she got caught with work
this whole going for sure break [ __ ]
plays a [ __ ] lot of [ __ ] yes website
[Music]
what happens me to keep on cursing holy
[ __ ]
I collect claim
- [ __ ] is that someone [ __ ] eating
the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you talking about okay
I want you to tell me why do you think
I'm mad - what Harrison Kane extension
405 Yolanda who the hell is your lambda
so this is what I found that [ __ ]
thing
holy [ __ ] you cheated on me and almost
kind of a prank out ah [ __ ] mad what
is the point of the [ __ ] light one
second bite holy [ __ ] there you really
[ __ ] that one up
Ashley what if I can say is that they
know one [ __ ] [ __ ]
I just read my text
that's [ __ ] how do we bit too much to
drink last night
and no idea what I was saying I'll make
it up to you okay I'm going back to
sleep so okay spark shoes all right
think about it what
I got my eyes on you this [ __ ] trying
hard far from it Taylor she's not around
you know she's your one we left low the
[ __ ] let's get practical Taylor stop
[ __ ] around
strength noise that [ __ ] at August 10th
this is that was another one yeah no
there's somewhere this me stuff right